you
there we go just got paired up here a
15-2 game alrighty let's see I'm playing
is black which I like that because the
last few 15-minute games playing white
so let's start out pretty flexible here
I don't have six I think I might have
played this guy before a different site
let's see not sure if it's the same guy
this name seems familiar though okay
well I guess we're going to go into a
Queen's Gambit or my decision really six
I could take it into a name so Indian
BOGO Indian well more a BOGO Indian if
East six and c4 I'm gonna go classical
approach just Queen's Gambit I'm
expecting c4 I'm gonna play e6 I don't
like on c4 c6 the exchange variation I
know it's pretty dry but uh I I don't
like playing the black side of that even
though it shouldn't really be much for
white so let's see with uh
already Knight f3 one thing I could
already say is that if it goes into mmm
if it goes into the the Queen's game but
with c4 in e6 I don't have to worry
about this central expansion with this
night already declaring himself on f3
but there's always that minority attack
so hmm
c4 isn't played right away so normally
with a quick pressure on this point you
have to lend support to it what I'm
considering right now is maybe to try
and get my Bishop outside here and then
get e6 in but I don't know that that's
uh and a work out so well another move I
could be considering is 94 with tempo
hmm
decisions I mean I could always just go
right into East 6 and then Bishop e7 I'm
gonna go into a Alaska defense line with
h6 and then 94 let's see I candidate
moves I'm really leaning towards e6 I'll
probably end up doing that but let me
consider hmm I really have time for this
Bishop f5 I'd be fine with Bishop takes
Knight Bishop f5 c4 that's kind of a bug
Bishop Bishop f5 c4 an e6 Queen b3 is
hard to me I want to be in a position to
me Queen b3 with Queen b6 yeah let's
just go with something simple it's worth
considering though you know whenever you
know this was most common on move three
for white so whenever there's some
change you try and find the differences
and maybe take advantage of it in some
way but I'm not so sure I'll have a look
at it afterwards with the stockfish but
uh yeah I D here's Bishop e7 castles h6
or I might even want to play h6 first
there might actually be a reason to do
that there's some tricky lines with I've
seen with h4 and g5 giving up the bishop
a knight or the bishop Knight exchange
okay and I'm not - and seen that too
much what's the great delay with c4 huh
okay I guess White's going for something
like III Bishop d3 retaining some
options with this pawn looking for an
eventual efore break with preparation
mm-hmm okay I need to get some
development in I think there's really a
better move than there and now I mean if
this C pawn isn't going to strike at my
deep on I might want to have my C pawn
play a more aggressive role with c5 hmm
I wonder if there's
situations where after Bishop Wow it's
gonna say after c5 Bishop takes Knight
Bishop takes Bishop on takes but would
be on b2 now this is surprising huh so
this is the approach giving up the
bishop pair huh I guess II four is the
idea giving
the bishop pair and as compensation
trying to get a little bit of a lead in
development or striking quick in the
center okay so this is the main battle
that's going on right now bishop pair
versus white having a slight space
advantage and mm-hmm
I don't know how great a lead in
development this guy how do I get him
working that's my that's my big question
here and actually at this moment here
what is what should I do
I hold my point on d5 hmm
I'd like to see this and then Bishop
back then I can die get in see five
pretty easy
there's a reason not to castle
hmm would I be coming under fire with
Bishop d3 captures here and h4 stuff
fishing pull stuff maybe uh I sure what
to do could always just take but I don't
like helping improve the night position
hmm
I'm not sure
candidate moves I should be going for
here v6 Bishop d7 also an IDM ipv6
Bishop to a6 only after this guy has
moved I don't know that I want a castle
so quick
I'm gonna go with this that's very
weakening and my King may be a bit
exposed on this diagonal by late let's
see see with white so White's gonna do
are they gonna play this pretty
automatic move Bishop d3 I'd be fine to
see this calmly come back even though I
have the bishop hair I still might be
the one who seeks a light square bishop
exchange I could still play a position
where I have this dark square Bishop if
these guys he pushes forward here these
pawns are fixed on dark squares and
could be a later target by this guy so I
really am
gonna be so quick to exchange him off
it's what I'm getting at I want to play
this position with him always on board
against one of these nights he we could
call him my bad Bishop currently
so be fine with exchanging him off and I
was pointing out that I would only want
to play let's say Bishop a6 after this
Bishop has moved that those are just for
tempo reasons timing reasons after the
bishop moves then I play here in that
way the Bishop has to move again before
he captures make this guy move twice in
other words before my light square
Bishop is exchanged I do have to watch
out for these sneaky tricks for as long
as my king is on e8 mmm well a white is
basically saying let's play an ending I
could force that if I wanted to huh I'm
not careful Bishop here could be a big
pain tempted to castle my first thought
though is to take the knight takes takes
pawn takes Knight takes I'm not sure how
to assess this ending I want to go for
it I'm not sure how well the knight will
stand on e4 and I think my king will
have a cozy home on e7
interesting
another thought is
why even need to like after Bishop takes
Knight pawn takes pawn takes does white
have to even recapture queen g4 might be
a move just to keep Queens on the board
and try and still play with this pawn on
e5 cramping my position a little bit hmm
not sure I might just castle keep this
option open for a little later yeah
maybe I'm not going
quick to give up this guy maybe only
after Bishop here will I do that
ah I think I want a castle yeah let's do
that
I've played enough positions with the
early Queen exchange so let's keep the
ladies on board for a little bit and now
I don't have to worry about this pawn
push at least this can't be a bad
position for my dark square bishop how
are we doing on the clock
not too bad it's been worse c5 is a
coming into consideration White has
moved this piece twice now by coming
under any serious attack I don't think
so now I might have to watch out for
this site this idea I was mentioning
earlier I might run into some trouble
with that now with this Knight jumping
into c6 or some combination of taking on
a6 and the knight c6 after I recapture
these guys I currently view as
offsetting one another
same diagonal two squares separating
them they're fighting for these same
squares D 7 C 6 it's just a way I try to
visualize the position certain the
relationship between certain pieces in
the game um candidate moves I'm
anticipating Bishop here I don't think
that this would be a good choice to take
here who knows now I haven't done so
well with predicting light spoofs up to
this point so who's to say that that's
going to change I don't think I've
predicted any move here from move 3 on I
thought c4 and it was Bishop g5 and then
one move later I thought c4 it was night
here and then not here ok and then
without even the capture on f6 so let's
prepare prepare for anything really be
prepared for anything
alrighty bishop they're sneaky miss well
what's wrong with just Bishop here
I wanna go here anyway that conveniently
defend this point let's develop I got
some moves in I think that bishops a bit
awkwardly placed you know c5 might be I
might be able to play c5 now with the
very serious threat with this Bishop
sticking around on this square
after c5 I might be threatening c4 and
then a6 b5
with it's right for many reasons I'm
gonna do it right away I didn't share
all the reasons but this one typically
you would want to strike at the dark
squares if you have this X Factor Bishop
this unopposed dark square bishop in
this case
striking at the opponent's ponds who
have dark square control that occupy the
dark squares eliminate them is going
eliminating them is going to
increase this bishops mobility
hmm Queen c7 is a new move I'm going to
square available for the Queenie I could
have considered taking this pun why
didn't I do that that what this doesn't
seem right hmm what am I missing
is threatening me and that's pretty
serious I also threatened this night
and also threatens
Pond
and then she's indirectly hitting this
bishop she's hitting everything
Wow
when he takes pawn what would
I'd have to do this positions opening up
by the way so this is good news for Team
dark-squared bishop
Wow Queen takes pawn
huh
I don't understand
cleany takes pawn is this some opening
trap I don't see it Queen takes pawn
let's just double-check mm-hmm Queen
takes pawn is pretty serious
how do you defend mate on G to Queen
here night here
Wow
don't see it
let's develop a new piece and threaten
me what am I missing
okay this is one of those show me show
me what the big plan is here tonight
here take this pawn
hitting the bishop Bishop c4
that might be the line but still I'm
opening up this position pretty much
even
time-wise not not that not the clocks
that are running here but Devon a
development standpoint pretty even if a
night here upon take spawn Bishop c4 I
could drop back just a single square to
d6 and keep pressure on this Knight
who's now going to need
some serious support and this is this
has to be good
I think stockfish would be lighting up
pretty good here 14 black huh
watch out for any trickiness here I
could even meet Bishop c4 with Queen c5
these guys are still offsetting one
another
sure seems all pretty good let's take
this guy what am I missing
I don't think anything so this will be
an eventual tempo gaining move rook a to
ca there's a convenient way to defend
that'll c6
I'll see three blunt this diagonal but
first and foremost how does black regain
this pawn can't do right away because
the pressure here I'm thinking Knight g4
that would be a way to kick my bishop
off of the defense of this pawn
but even so clean trade I have the
bishop pair the positions open it should
be good
trying to stay on top clockwise because
I believe the position is pretty good
huh Queen here I feel like I'm close to
winning material like very very close
Queen here keeping pressure on both
minor pieces and staying in a position
to defend my pawn
ok-hee
takes pawn here tricks I don't see that
happening
let's go right here I have this square
covered these guys same story they're
still offsetting one another Oh actually
something I just missed there hmm I was
thinking I could take here and after the
queen recapture well I always thinking
the night would after he captured but my
rook would be lose here so now it's a
little bit tricky for me to develop yeah
I missed that
wait a second
takes night Bishop takes Knight Queen
takes
I can take with
I could take Bishop takes Knight here
Queen takes rook and then Queen takes
bishop I get the two minor pieces so I'm
Bishop takes the knight has to recapture
and then I just develop and I'm stopped
this pond
this is transitioning to uh I'll just
play the position up upon still
just double-check here
takes nine Queen takes
if Queen takes Bishop takes Knight Queen
takes my rook Queen takes my bishop I
have pretty good coordination in fact
I'd be on c2 at that point
ok let's go for it so night here night
c6 and things are looking pretty smooth
diagonal here any pressure here is a
convenient reply g6 to blunt the light
squares keep control over the light
squares have my pawns here they'd be in
good harmony with my dark square bishop
hmm okay something went wrong for white
here but let's see if I could convert
this well I want to try and be
very accurate from a technical
standpoint here
okay and this was my idea let's say I
get some moves in here I got to go
faster I should have been considering
Bishop takes pawn but now that's not
working
I have everything defended here
if we have the night
in exchange I wouldn't mind playing that
end game even though it's opposite color
bishops this guy is still something hmm
what's that move
I don't understand what that move is
I'm sure where to go my bishop here
let's uh let's stay
this pond staff of light square
initially I was thinking here but I'm
not so sure about that Bishop here might
be annoying at some stage you know just
trying to stay nice and tucked in here
staying coordinated I could have
considered Bishop here getting the
Knights exchanged that I should have
done that I would have forced a knight
exchange because I'd be on this
unless night here but that seems awkward
rook here I'm aunt Isabel now I'm not
anticipating anything really huh sneaky
on about a queen trade
uh not sure hear that crazy dogs I don't
know
shoot for
let's shoot for this quaint red coin
trade or not my knight is a loose piece
a night here I'm gonna go Bishop here on
Queen here I'm Queen here what do I do
Queen here I could drop my queen back
then I have a night here maybe that's
fine Queen here is a nice a nice spot I
think
I wonder if 94 Bishop back f4 that's
that's really weakening the light
squares or the dark squares whoa
okay so they're okay with the Queen
exchange
and
I am too I got a I got a play faster
here so
let's get right here changing my mind I
wanna get my rook here stop upon I have
a two to zero majority in the center
let's back up that's my knee-jerk
reaction right there but I think it's
good Bishop here Bishop Bishop a6 rook
here
rook da slowly improved my king position
not gonna be so quick to play this move
I don't think let's get here less than
four they have five two second increment
though right here to here might be an
idea
hmm timely kick of this night hmm
that's so fast I'm not going to commit
my pawns just yet let's inch my king
over just a hair
I hear - here still tough to convert
this for sure whoo
well I don't have to worry about this
pond anymore huh well that's interesting
what about this move first right now
yeah because then the night can't
recapture after pawn takes I think now
is the time to do this
yeah let's give this guy a kick so I'm
gonna have not only a pawn up but maybe
a second one and a structural defect
this guy could fall I think this is a
losing move
yeah I'm gonna win another pond here I
think and I will take him
yeah and my bishop will have a good
was done c5 or is this Nyko he only has
two options here he's kind of biting on
a rock here he's getting in the way of
this he might need to do this just do
just to maybe forced me on the retreat
here pawn takes rook takes Bishop takes
mm yeah and this is how I would want to
recapture I don't want to recapture with
my knight I'm really displacing him
whereas the bishop not so much he's
easily re repositioned to good square so
I guess they maybe miscalculated
something there I didn't expect the f5
move could get back on this diagonal as
well the only reason I retreated was
because the knight played here
my rook is unprotected on c7 I might be
if I might have to be a little bit
cautious of some pin here and then
piling up on it the knight never goes
here is that a problem no my first
thought is to take I should probably do
it stay ahead on the clock here no there
is a reason to take with the night I
want to keep pressure here my mistake
let's do this yeah this is much more
clear so now I'm going to win that a
three pawn or should I take this one I
think I want to do this I'm going to
take with the bishop because this is
helping improve my King position you got
to take this pawn to he's past if you
don't push him rook here isn't working I
could take doesn't matter that he's
unprotected in that case he'd be pushing
through so I'm pawn takes Bishop takes
pawn that's my idea and just to improve
my
position or his rook takes better I
think I'm gonna go with the rook
actually rook takes cuz then I'm on this
Bishop takes pawn and pawn here I don't
want to allow that when I take with the
rook yeah let's take with the rook how
do you defend any three I'm up two pawns
now even if it's a opposite color Bishop
ending this is uh-huh it'd be difficult
for white to hold that was a color
bishop bending so this is my thought
bishop right here post up on a nice
strong square here King e7 yeah let's
stay aggressive
keep pressure here Knight here get on
the second-ranked keep pressure enough
to
to prove my king position this is no
issue here Oh actually it might be
hmm second rank yeah I should get their
keep
pin down rook here King e2 Bishop here
check King f6
rook takes their this is probably what's
going to happen
I probably shouldn't allow this
counterplay I should maybe just move my
knight
night here
yeah this is the plan
get my knight out right away Knight here
- here
I shouldn't have allowed this much
Connor play I was missing Bishop here in
the reckoning to my second rank
I gotta watch out for their back rank
though I here to here is serious
the bishop here
the night here
okay let's go right here
uh-huh keep thinking I'm missing
something I may be missing something but
I don't know about that rook check King
here there's a rook check here King f6
okay now I could do this mmm that's so
sure about that let me maybe play here
or here actually
you
this will secure my night position
maybe I should consider that
you
tricky pawn push rook here King here f4
I could play night here too here though
let's get my king up
if f/4 I'm gonna play
night here and then this ooh I wasn't
expecting that actually quite happy to
see that
I will take that
I can defend my second-ranked
now to play some fast moves here
actually I don't need to defend my
second-ranked let's secure my night
position now
had a flame
practical let me just cover all my
basics I'm here to here
here the Bishop's going to buy
Meowth
okay
I reposition a little bit
my one of
inserted some checks here just a bank
sometime
ah rook trade
this should be winning
hmm
okay let's do this
and get my knight right here
and I move faster
you
12 seconds okay how to win this pressure
on that pond
especially was always a bit tricky I
don't know if this is the correct
direction I going but I'm gonna try it
create a passed pawn
gonna stop my pawn in fact it's not so
easy okay now I know how to win this one
definitely know how to win this one from
here I'm gonna hunt down that pawn
okay sorry about the dog
in the background too much I could do
about that
alright I'm hitting the bishop and I'm
pushing through now and this Knight is
boxing out the bishop
all right they're just
the end got another pond here to run
with
King here and then push through my night
controls this square now stalemates I'm
just gonna play it out to the end here
yeah we're going to
computer had to say but this one watch
out for stealing it's not closed though
okay keep going almost there
homestretch
you
and there we go all right let me give me
a second here
and bring up stock fish and see what he
has to say
okay let's see what stockfish has to say
with this one so I'll let you guys know
where it changed up the evaluation wise
computer is pretty much never gonna like
Bishop takes Knight there but it's uh
it's gonna be playable but I don't know
if white treated at the the correct way
with playing against the the bishop hair
cuz I was able to open the position up
doesn't have any issue with b6 typical
computer move is just a castle right
away zero fear of uh any attacks this is
this is something I was uh had some
concern by me I ideas like this where
there's a push and then pawn push and
then Bishop sacrifices and then Knight
jumping and here stuff but uh computer
just plays Queen b6 and goes pawn
hunting but I'm not so sure about that I
definitely didn't want to uh I wanted to
at least be mindful of this idea and my
playing b6 here was too well I played b6
instead of castling because I didn't
want to contend with these possibilities
of sacrifices on h7 and h4 Knight g5
stuff so I went with this getting my
queen Bishop out it doesn't like that
Knight move a prefers Bishop to d3 and
says it's even after Knight here it's a
slight advantage for white and by slight
I mean negative 0.35 ish something
around their castles Bishop there okay
yeah didn't like this move struck me as
a bit awkward Bishop d3 once again just
a bearing
on this diagonal you know I was pointing
out that this is the bishop that I
really need to get working and
white-white has a slight space advantage
that's some a little bit of the the
battle that's going on in it there that
was going on in this game or maybe
should have gone on in this game another
way to look at it is that if he isn't
well he's he's a Queen side specific
piece this is the Queen Bishop but he's
not like outside here he's not
contributing on the Kings side of the
board and so another approach for white
is to post up like this and try and make
something happen on this diagonal
because he's maybe not so quick to
exchange of self off for this guy one of
the ideas I had was this mm-hmm I guess
there aren't any tricks I was wondering
if there was like Knight here or some
combination of a capture here and then
here but it's never really amounting to
much this is just a one move threat
Queen d7 is apparently fine but yeah
Bishop Bishop to b5 was a bit awkward
this is now it's reading as about a pawn
advantage for black so I think this was
a step in the wrong direction this isn't
no this really isn't inconveniencing me
mm-hmm it's ready to throw a night here
but Bishop d7 is a convenient way I was
gonna go here anyhow and then he just
watches over c6 castles and the
advantage is climbing yeah it likes D
take c4 I didn't even consider that I'm
not sure why do you take c4 right there
it's okay with c5 still about a pawn
advantage and I think this is a really
the step in the wrong direction
I imagine that the evaluation isn't
going to shift too much unless there was
some tactics missed but I think the main
point was the bishops decision to play
here
maybe the knight you jumping into e5 was
that's and that's how accurate it's Ted
going for more development would have
been better
Peter likes a six here that did not even
come to mind what's that what's the
trick with that night before Bishop c4
Knight takes a - yeah don't know that I
really want to go for that and he just
going for blunder checks here I should
have done this just to make it uh a bit
easier to play at least opposite colored
bishops would be tough to break down
though but this Bishop having a
fantastic home on d3 I need to get these
guys working and I'd have to be very
careful about how exactly I move them
forward I don't want to create any
serious light-square weaknesses as I do
that that's maybe asking a bit much I
imagine it's uh fine the approach I took
here
it likes ninety four here 94 in the game
what was played there a three night a
four I was going to do this on this move
is there anything crazy okay it does
suggest this Queen c7 move that might be
a little bit scary computer has no
problem reading +2 now I guess that's
not really working out d3 ha with night
here sneaky okay these are the only
things I was concerned about because I'm
still up this pawn here so I'm looking
for like these concrete strikes these
this very direct play but it never
really came queens are off I'm still up
this pawn and does it ever slip any
tactics missed it's about a pond pond
and a half advantage climbing now it's
plus two and beyond I guess we could
expect that at this point it ever
slipped right around here this is where
I thought this is where I thought
force should be played in fact instead
of king to e7 it does like this g5 most
something I was going to do but unrep
checking here is what I plan and this
should still be alright but it's
allowing a bit more activity than I
would have liked in the end I decided on
King here because on f4 this is what I
was going to play Knight here and that
is the that is the move the computer
likes and unrep check King f6 is what I
had planned and this should be really
devastating a knight jumping in here
best line is apparently to take and then
not give this check although it's still
about upon and a half advantage it likes
Knight here who probably wouldn't have
played that I guess one of the ideas is
to maybe jump in here hmm in the event I
was happy to see this move Knight here
because it simplified the position and
made it a lot easier for me to
consolidate getting my knight on d6 is a
good way to deal with the coordination
of rook and Bishop getting to d7 and
then it frees up my rook to do other
things
they were exchanged and this is really
the last key point I don't want to allow
the King to try and enter and anyway I
want to get my King here and my knight
here and once that's on board then it's
not really much he could do and I wasn't
able to say it at this point either
during the game but I didn't want to do
something like this to support because
these these pawns are now being fixed on
light squares so I wasn't able to share
it at the time but I was thinking of
just taking and that's what that's what
I did in the game and then playing here
now I only have one pawn on a light
square but he's easily defended and
conveniently defended because my king
wants to be in the center anyway and
he's right there to defend him so this
is just turning out to be a one King and
well
just a one ending here nothing could
ever slipped this this Bishop takes a
long while to get back on this diagonal
here since I have that control over D
four plus five and Beyond and yeah this
is of course going to be winning all
right interesting game this was a pretty
long video but anyway feel free to share
what any comments you have in the
comment section below and I will catch
you in the next video take care bye
you